drones como estos son los ojos de
ucrania en el cielo y determina la
estrategia de su ejército los operadores
están siendo atacados por soldados rusos
que quieren impedir que el ejército
ucraniano descubra sus ubicaciones
yo creo que la misión de hoy fue útil
hemos identificado a rusos construyendo
fortificaciones y reforzando sus
posiciones
el ejército ucraniano dice que las
fuerzas rusas en la región de gerson son
vulnerables después de que ucrania
destruyera varios puentes en el río
mipro golpeando las líneas de suministro
rusas ucrania señala que también puede
bombardear otros puentes que rusia
intenta construir
por el momento rusia no puede enviar
refuerzos del lado izquierdo del río ni
pro entonces están creando una ilusión
de envío de refuerzos trasladando
unidades del ejército de un lugar a otro
pero moscú ofrece una perspectiva
diferente al ministro de defensa ruso
anunció el martes que una contraofensiva
ha fracasado y que las fuerzas rusas
habían derrotado la brigada separada de
asalto a la montaña si se confirma eso
puede ser una pérdida significativa para
ucrania
las acciones efectivas de la agrupación
rusa de tropas destruyeron 48 tanques 46
vehículos de infantería otros 37
vehículos blindados de combate 8
camionetas y más de 1200 soldados
ucranianos
d es la primera vez que ucrania ha
pasado a la ofensiva en el sur tras dos
semanas de estancamiento gerson es un
área estratégica con acceso al mar negro
y retomar su control expondrá los
avances de rusia en ucrania